hello freak bitches so it's a great it's
the idea of infinite universes saddens
people you know what it just when
something looks that big it makes people
depressed now when you tell people like
maybe there are infinite lives that we
are all living you know all
consecutively all right next to each
other and they're all completely
different the idea that is like oh it's
like I am just barely getting through
the pack the fact that I'm you know
living here in America on earth in 2010
I'm barely barely wrapping my head
around that the idea that there's
billions and billions and then that
we're gonna redo this every 15 billion
years is gonna be a new Big Bang and
people are gonna eventually evolved out
of amoebas and fish and fucking lizards
and rabbits and monkeys and and then
humans with it really it just keeps
going over and over and over and over
and over and over again can I tell you
my new theory of reincarnation yes and
it's really intense because I thought it
wasn't it freaked me out it's pretty
horrible so it's like the common idea of
reincarnation if you subscribe to the
theory is that you die and you're born
again you go through your childhood you
grow up and then you die maybe you get
born as a cat maybe a butterfly right
maybe an amoeba this is what I was
thinking because I had a dream once and
in this dream I was a kid a little girl
and my mom was rubbing my head and I
knew I was dying but I didn't know what
that meant
except I knew it was bad and I could
kind of feel myself fading out there was
this like white sort of thing happening
and then I woke up out of the dream like
fuck what a shitty dream so I was
thinking like oh fuck what if that's
what reincarnation is what if when you
die you know when you're driving home
one night you've had too many pot
lollipops you're listening to coast to
coast someone says something shocking
that makes you look away from the road
you swerve off you slam into a tree you
wake up you're here back in your house I
got fuck what a shitty dream but you've
really died you just reincarnated again
into an alternate route in an alternate
reality so you literally can't die
there's no break this just goes on
forever and ever
ever and ever no break no stopping no
new age going into the light and seeing
your parents and your family and taking
a going to some new age cosmic spa where
you get to shake off all your shitty
karma it never stops
it just keeps happening again again
maybe like right now there's an
earthquake and the ceiling collapses and
all of a sudden you're just some
daydreaming cabbie in Boston like well I
was fucking weird I was just imagining I
was a comedian in LA but you know what I
mean well that's bizarre
you're gonna change lives no become the
guy rides this body out yeah you snap
into an alternate life with all your
memories embedded everything already
embedded in there because it's an
infinite it's an infinite this the the
Joe Jon forever
what if your consciousness is living a
bunch of different life simultaneously
and you just can't you can't see them
yes like an office filled with cubicles
and no one's poking their head over the
top of the cubicle yeah right all
rolling at the same time yeah or like
the way I thought about it is like if
you're if there was like something this
it sounds really crazy but imagine that
each of your fingers this sounds insane
but imagine like each of your fingers
had their own personality in their own
like consciousness or something it's
like and you could stick them through
some kind of hole where they would
forget they were attached to your hand
and they would just think that they were
their own individual self you know what
I mean like maybe that's what we are
we're just like little fingers
protruding into this dimension from some
infinite thing but the product of
protruding into this dimension is we get
instantaneous amnesia and part of like
dealing with a shock of coming into this
dimension is we forget our true identity
and replace it with our ego structure
Wow well one of the things that yes